hey guys how's it going so one thing
that you guys have always said to me is
justine why do you not get some artwork
in your house i'm a huge fan of
minimalism so i don't like anything on
my walls i have never had a single piece
of artwork in any of my apartments that
i've had for however long i've been
living on my own which is quite a while
i think this goes back to my parents
because i used to like thumb tack stuff
into my walls and they would always yell
at me so
since then i've just decided you know
what i don't really want anything my
balls this is a milestone in my life
because i have purchased my first piece
of artwork in this tube and i haven't
opened it yet because i wanted to open
it for you guys i wanted to share with
you i've been eyeing this thing out for
the past couple of years and finally for
my birthday i decided that it's time a
birthday gift of some art
oh come on now i'm burning it
we didn't start the fire
please don't learn what is inside of
here i would be so sad i'm also gonna
need your assistance with what type of
frame you think i would need for this i
have never framed anything either go
figure the lip was always burning
the big
unveiling
this is a big day for me and i'm glad
that you're all here
oh here it is okay
this
is
the most exciting day ever
i can't even see you guys
i can't see you
and here you have it my first
piece of one of a kind
16 out of 100 of a kind prince by susan
carr who is one of the original
designers of the macintosh icons you see
those icons she designed those for the
macintosh in 1980s something two three
what about all these icons recognize
them huh no
probably because you were born after we
stopped using floppy disks anyway i'm
just really excited because i cannot
wait to hang this up please leave me
some suggestions on types of frames to
get if you've ever framed anything
before i certainly have not i don't know
i think i'm just going to take it to the
frame store and say please
do whatever it is that you will do thank
you guys for watching don't forget to
like don't forget to subscribe and i
will see you guys in my next video let
me know what your
favorite artist is like who is your
favorite who's your favorite artist
there end of question leave in the
comments below and i'll see you guys
later bye
you